[Music]
what does sacrifice mean to you
means being selfless committed
now our tradition here is unlike any
other
we're family
now ray these scholarships are yearly
you perform on the field you perform in
the classroom
and if you don't they take that all away
yes coach
[Music]
you can't be satisfied
there's no guaranteed spot on my team
it's my brother
again baymar
this mama
ray earlier this morning i got her into
a 30-day inpatient program
we'll be placing feymar in foster care
can i just have a family member
watch me it's cool you should be getting
back to school anyway i'll be good
something in me is awakening
uh-huh wait
i'll take them all day praying that i
wouldn't make it i had to bring my
little brother to live with me on campus
find a motivation
[Music]
may we build bridges and break limits
mom's going
it's just doing me trying to make a
better way when the day's finished you
don't have to do this on your own
for the future and this is our story i
just want to leave a page in it
why are you helping me uh-huh everyone's
family here
my brother and i had it kind of tough
growing up
[Music]
clemson has given me the opportunity to
change my life
my coaches my teammates
these men are my brothers too history in
the making
you've been waiting for this your whole
[Music]
life
[Music]
you